What does America mean to you
Your removal is final there's nothing you can do sorry, but this is my home New York is my home
13.8 billion years ago the Big Bang created the Stars the planets the galaxies
Compared to the lifespan of the universe our lives begin and end in a single day
No, Daniel Natasha
Calls home. What are they about? Wait, let me guess
Not all of them I don't believe in love so no magic no fate
No meant to be what if I told you I could get you to fall in love with me
Just give me a day an hour
When your key ingredients to fall in love my ingredients our friendship chemistry The X Factor, what's the X Factor
Don't worry. We've got it
This isn't gonna make me change my mind, mr. Plaid tie, did you just call me Pat?
I'm glad time. My family is from Korea not Thailand. That is not what I said so you can stop waiting for an apology
Oh, I'm waiting for something but not for an apology
Now I don't know
But I think I could love
Oh
My gosh yo, what are you so afraid of listen, I wasn't born here what my family is leaving tomorrow
This is real and I know feel it too
The choice we make
The path you choose you don't have forever
All we have is a single day